hey youtubers is charlie and the walking
dead season 4 finale is this sunday so
since I've already done a bunch of
videos with XYZ predictions I thought it
would be really fun to ask a question in
this video how do you top the season 3
finale and the mid-season finale without
just repeating the same old stuff you
know how do you raise the intensity
level without just adding X number of
guns X number of tanks X number of
walkers the answer is really simple you
just make things much more intimate much
more personal you really have to change
your core characters in ways that
fundamentally alter the way you and I as
the audience perceive them as well as
other characters on the show perceive
them well what does that mean we have to
re-examine the season 3 finale in order
to understand and just compare that
against where the characters are right
now emotionally number one there was the
governor the black hat wearing villain
he was actually brought out after
complaints that the show lacked a
central villain for the audience to
rally around it totally worked in the
show became even more popular the
mid-season finale really can be
considered the end of his arc on the
show so what's going to take the place
of the Darth Vader of Georgia and what's
going to take the place of the Andrea
Milton element you know the really
personal element you can't just throw
away that broad threat to the group but
you really do have to intensify the
really intimate threat to someone you
love number two the comics the source of
all walkers you totally can't have a
story about the show without addressing
the comic the writers are literally
adapting the comic to make episodes you
know that being said a lot of stuff gets
changed for various reasons which is
where we find ourselves right now we've
got some new people in a new place being
led by a very ominous feeling Garrett
character suddenly it almost sounds like
the exact same sequence of events is
going to unfold so here's what we can
confirm right now Robert Kirkman said
that Gareth is a really interesting
twist on a comic book character if
Abraham Eugene and Rosita are any
indicator the person Gareth resembles
will look very close to someone in the
comics that the actor playing him
resembles that could be one of any of at
least four characters Robert Kirkman
really made it sound like that Gareth
character is a spin on one
and not multiple comic book characters
so we can localize our guesses to people
in the comic books based on where the
story is right now which really leads us
to hunters on the other hand terminus is
not something from the comic books but
it is the last stop before they go to
Alexandria so it does support that
hunters theory number three the terminus
hunters so if you have this very similar
situation to the season three finale
unfolding how do you do it differently
in a way that does not just have more
guns more tanks more walkers and doesn't
just swap that Darth Vader for another
Sith Lord I think it's really important
to remember how the Andrea Milton
situation unfolded we never got to see
him turn and then chow down on her they
chose not to show us that and instead
focused more on the governor with his
you know Death Star machine-gun just
mowing down people so what I think will
happen is is they'll just shift focus
and the largest portion of the story the
action will be in that locked room and
when I say that I'm just using that as a
metaphor for something horrific you know
something so unthinkable that you can't
eat for a few days you know mass murder
like the governor did during season
three is really abstract so it's a
little bit easier to shake off but
Andrea situation is just so much more
personal so it's just really hard to get
out of your mind number four the
breaking point Rick will totally be the
one to break in this episode that's what
the description means Rick comes
face-to-face with shocking brutality
that threatens everyone's lives
essentially it just means that he's
going to have to take a page from the
governor's book and eliminate whatever
threat is at terminus he's been farmer
Rick for most of the season but remember
what Carol said before they split you
can be a farmer Rick you can't just be a
farmer one of the reasons Karl lashed
out at him in episode 9 was because he
just become so ineffectual as a result
of this new chosen profession there's
this really old chess analogy you know
the best move is to make no move it just
means that the best action the
characters could take is to take no
action but I feel like walking dead does
not let its characters do that you can't
do that without paying a huge price what
does that mean in a practical sense well
it means Rick is going to brutally kill
a lot of people in a really up close and
personal way if you want to see a good
example of this in
read issue 57 it deals with the
Marauders which I think are represented
by Jose group I also think that you know
brutality of Rick's is going to carry
over into the people at terminus and
number five terminus is totally not a
good place even scumbag Joe agrees
terminus is bad news that tells you
everything you need to know about it but
there's also the similarities between me
sean's painting and Mary and the fact
that Mary is wearing a poncho that's
very similar to the one Beth was wearing
when she was kidnapped red warning
lights flashing everywhere so here's
where we have to talk about threats to
the group you know the big overarching
threats and even if the people at
terminus aren't carbon copies of the
hunters they're probably at least
inspired by them as in you know
practicing cannibals meaning that some
of the survivors are probably going to
get eaten or at least partially eaten
this all Ben's a lot of stuff from the
comics but again terminus and Gareth are
both totally new things that are just
inspired by elements of the comics the
real conversation we need to be having
at this point though is who's going to
get eaten and who's going to get
partially eaten so number six final
death predictions Maggie is still
totally my best guess based on all the
rumors and things from the comics that
have just been flipped remember how do
you top that scene with Andrea you show
it playing out in excruciating detail
with someone even more precious to you
which could be any number of people at
this point but Beth Carol Glenn they're
all marked I think we all expect Rick to
limp away from this again but he could
totally be one of those people that
limps away minus a limb or two so now
it's your turn let me know what would
you do to this finale to make it better
than the season 3 finale and the prison
massacre without just repeating events
really the thing that I want to see most
is Daryl rescue Beth and then just mow
down a bunch of terminus people
hopefully he'll find a new poncho
whenever he's wearing a poncho his crit
rating like doubles it's like boom
headshot boom headshot so in related
news i'll be posting my finale video
after the episode airs be sure to
subscribe below to get it also be doing
a double giveaway that's right two
people will get gift cards instead of
just one also be doing a season 5
predictions video next week once I get
through my Q&A right now click here
to catch up on this season and click
here for my latest QA thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys this
weekend high fives